what's up guys liv cook here and some of
you may already know me
as a freestyle footballer world champion
in fact
but i am not here today for that no no
no no i've put the football down because
today
i want to learn from the property legend
samuel leeds so this
is a three-day vlog shadowing the man
himself
let's go
all right so it is about 9am and i've
just arrived in
beautily look at this place the nature
the air
it even smells good and we are here at
ribsford castle
this is samuel leeds's current and
ongoing castle development the famous
one so
let's go check it out and shut my door
[Music]
look at this place it is massive now
samuel bought this about a year ago
for 800 000 pounds at auction and
it's got like a lot of heritage to this
building it used to be a training camp
for the french soldiers in the world war
so like when you're walking around you
can see that holes in the ground
where they used to stick the flag and
stuff is really interesting but
that is what makes it so difficult so
because it's got so much history this
building
it's actually a grade two star listed
which means
you need like permission from the local
council and the heritage team
to do almost anything like changing door
handles
can be a nightmare and changing window
frames you have to get the same ones
made so it becomes really expensive
and that's why this project is taking so
long but it's also why you got it so
cheap so 800 000 pounds
at auction for this massive building and
he's spending about 3 million pounds on
it
and currently it's got a gdv of 6.35
million pounds oh here he is
the man himself this is ben
samuel's right hand how are you i'm
divided i'm good thank you
thank you good to see you again as
always
i know right i know i know working day
yeah i'm just um bigging up the camera
look and the numbers yeah your amazing
work your baby isn't it
yeah yeah see from getting this bad boy
finished yeah big meeting this morning
though right big meeting today
so what is that that's the local
heritage team local council
yeah exactly so it's going to be a bit
of a exploration
okay i'll see what else we can do to um
to add more value to this already
amazing products
so the current gdp is 6.35 million right
and you've already got permission for
all of that
yes but this morning you're meeting
you're going in for more permission yeah
potentially yeah so if you get it
what kind of gdv are we looking at early
days yet come on come on
you want to say it come on say it you
want to say it
part of you wants to say i'd love to add
another two or three to it but we'll see
another two or three another two or
three minutes you see the way you say
it's not like
just another two or three minutes we'll
see how you know but it's another two or
three
early early days earlier yeah so
yeah it's exciting though i'm excited to
be a fly on the wall in this meeting
yeah yeah please
we won't get in the way no it's all good
it's all good um
but yeah so i'm just gonna check see
everything's okay we're gonna meet
outside today
and uh see how where we get to the end
of it
but you managed to get rid of the bat no
it's still good they're still there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so overall it went very well
we've currently got planning permission
for
just four houses and ten apartments and
basically they've said in principle
that we can have we've got planning for
12 apartments and about houses
so it's like it's going to increase the
gross development value by a lot
there's one thing that they like and
they'll be like yeah you can have it
and that difference is millions of
pounds yeah exactly that's insane and
also
and i think as well when people don't
know me
if you just watch me on youtube and then
i'm not at the meeting they might just
think oh i've seen him he's a bit of a
loud mouth
yeah i know let's not give it to him and
i think you and ben together is a really
good match ben's amazing isn't it
so tomorrow
obviously a barrier but could it also be
a an advantage in some way i mean is it
likely to affect the prices in any way
or is it
is it possibly a the only advantage
would be it's easier to get planning at
the moment
yeah so costs haven't dropped house
prices haven't dropped
at all how long is that going to last
oh i think i don't know but i would
imagine sort of probably
january as the as the furlough money
runs out and his bounce back loans stop
being given out and things
and speaking from a personal perspective
there's benefits of covid in the sense
that i'm not crazy busy
usually i'm flying country to college oh
yeah of course of course so
if kirby hadn't happened would i be sat
here right now
probably not no so yes you're making hey
while you can
exactly and then how did the
relationship with samuel start i mean
that was something
the internet professional relationship
i just messaged you on instagram right
just found them yeah yeah oh yeah
all right hi samuel be great to have a
chat if you're available for a facetime
sometime soon i'm just getting into the
real estate market
there we go see right there but don't
get me wrong i get people messaging me
all the time
that are well known have a high profile
that'll argue and i don't spend time
with them like i do
live so it's not just like oh she's got
four million followers it's not like
that i think we're quite similar though
in the sense that i wasn't just dabbling
like i said that to you as soon as i
said yeah and i also wikita and i saw
that she
on her wikipedia page actually said
she's just set up a property company and
i just thought i want to be part of this
you know what i mean if liver just said
to me i'm interested in doing property
one day i'd have probably then just said
to her okay cool
you know giving her just a little bit of
her giving her a link to some video or
whatever how do you like the risk i mean
i mean
a little bit i'm not a warrior you're
not worried you'll go for it if you
think it's a bit of a definitely like
i'm not stupid with it if like two
options present themselves and one's got
less risk then obviously i'm gonna go
with that
but i'm not i'm willing to risk
everything because
i'll always bet on myself like if it's
down to me
then i'd risk everything because i trust
myself because i know i'll put whatever
work is needed
but if the risk is out of my control i
might be a bit more cautious but
i'm young and i don't worry like i i
could lose everything tomorrow
and there is no doubt in my mind i'll
rebuild it yeah in fact it'd be quite
exciting
like take everything watch me build it
again you've seen success would do that
so many times as well
yes successes it's not look like
if you've got lucky then you might get
one project that does well
you might do one tv show that did well
one viral video
but if you've maintained that success
for years like
i know what success takes to become the
best in the world
you work your ass off and it's years and
years of
dedication people can't even begin to
imagine to become the best on the planet
or something
so i understand that and that is why i
just believe myself so much
so you're massively driven yeah i just
trust myself and trust the process
and you'll do the work 100 tomorrow's
gonna be a fun day
yeah today's been good though i've
learned a lot that meeting was really
yeah
that meeting was great yeah it was i
learned a lot so
yeah thanks for today that's all right
should we get going then well tomorrow's
an early start right
tomorrow first meeting is at 8 00 am 8
am
which is the pipes
good morning people so it's about 7am
and i'm heading right now
to go and meet with samuel we're going
to meet in about half an hour
before his 8 a.m meeting let's go
look at these the man himself the legend
that is
so cool
okay so samuel is actually in this room
now it's about
8 am so he's just got on a call with a
guy called raheem who used to be a
student he might still be actually
um but rahim has a business proposal for
him so he's dealing with that
and then straight after that he's
actually on stage in his very room
for his training academy there's only
like 10 people because i covered
but it looks pretty cool
[Music]
so
welcome to the business of property
investing
um you know all of our programs we have
super high energy because i really
believe that big
energy means big money would you agree
yes or no yes yes
and listen people say this if the house
is good
it sells itself
have you heard this yes or no but that
is the most ridiculous thing ever
if you're a deal seller guess what
people need to know your deal seller
and on this over these two days believe
you me people are going to know you
exist
but is everyone going to like you
unfortunately not but you know what some
people won't like you because the color
of your t-shirt you can't help that
people's people spend so much time
on all they care about is being liked
that's how most people live i just want
to be liked
i just want to be liked
you need to leave that at the door on
the business of property investing
it doesn't just need to be liked you
decide i just need to be known
i just need people to know that my
product exists i just need people to be
aware
i am very very impressed samuel's
obviously got the knowledge of the
industry we know that we've known that
he wouldn't be
at the level he's at without that
knowledge so he's good at that but it's
one thing having the knowledge
and one thing being able to deliver and
capture an audience like he's just done
so when he says he's a property investor
developer and a trainer
the two things are completely different
it's like me with freestyle there's one
thing being a freestyler
but to be able to coach someone it's
completely different you have to
understand things
very different and the way he speaks and
the way he's
like high energy enthusiastic captivates
the audience
and almost lets them navigate
what he wants to talk about but really
he knows all along what he's talking
about but the way he does it and he gets
them to answer questions or ask
questions it's very very clever he's a
very talented guy
and these people are here for two days
for this event and
i know they're going to learn a lot it's
going to be awesome but we're swimming
samuel now here he is
yeah we're heading off gender reveal
time oh yeah you're excited
[Applause]
how are you doing how are you doing
you're excited to go yeah hello nice to
meet you
at last i feel like we've already met i
know have you got it in there have you
looked at it
yeah i know i know what it is
[Applause]
it is a drum roll i'm happy all the way
it's a girl
oh that is me so is it jessica
jessica oh that's a lovely name i am
really pleased
i know i was like i was like his heart's
gonna burn
oh you can't even do it you excited yeah
do you come to this house with us yeah
yeah i'll come with you it's in 12
minutes from here
cool yeah should we go yeah
so this one looks quite interesting so
this came up on rightmove
a couple of days ago it's got planning
permission to build two detached houses
at the rear so yeah it looks dead
exciting
this is actually for my development so
yes this is part of samuel's day so it's
in this vlog
but this is for a development that i'm
looking for and he's helping me
mentoring me through the process
[Music]
it's not as simple as we thought
with the road situation the access it
depends on the numbers doesn't it but i
think you keep the bundle and refurbish
because it looks at the same standard as
the one next to it so be keen to know
how much that
is valued and sold for i think we just
need to do more fact finding we just
need to find out
what the place what the planning
permission is how
what the um what the houses are yeah the
two bed three bed four bed
and how much is going to cost to get
that road yeah
if you can i don't think you'll extend
the road
i think you'll have their driveway and
then put a drop down curb
yeah well we're back at the house at
about half fury
awesome okey-dokey then well enjoy the
rest of your day
every day we will see you later okay
guys
yo could you let me in brian you guy
yeah
so is there a reason that the office is
at the side of his house
can he expense his house or something
yeah but not many people would want
their office at the house
it's cool it's just if you've got a
meeting you've got everyone coming to
your house
yeah some people wouldn't like that no
but russell's like me he just lives and
breathes work so yeah okay
that's why he lives in a house like this
yeah because he lives and breeds what he
does
wow look at this house so this is
russell's house
russell is obviously samuel's brother
and business partner
and their new company office is actually
this building here
so it's not finished yet it's still in
development but let's go check it out
it's gonna save them a ton of money
because for their offices in london they
were paying like 20
000 pounds a month so more efficient
because you're not traveling to work and
saves a hell of a lot of money
win-win
i've actually read russell's book i
don't know if he knows like
i know who he is and i follow him and
everything but this is our first time
meeting
i felt like this is such an important
meeting that we kind of wanted to be
here
um so i'll go make this call while you
sort that out man cool and uh yeah all
right
thanks for all being here though i
appreciate it and i'm excited
i know it's actually samuel
hey
[Music]
so take it take it as a yes and i look
forward to hearing from you when you
tell me you've got your first deal and i
look forward to celebrating
all right and if you need any help if
you get stuck book another call
here we go call one down it's a
no-brainer she wasn't really asking you
the question she wanted confirmation
yeah reassurance but a lot of people do
you want that she's lacking confidence
yep so what we're going to do now we're
going to go back to my house which is
like literally
10 minutes away if that um and we're
going to do we've got
a few youtube videos to quickly bang out
um
that's it really a little bit of filming
[Applause]
[Music]
live cookies house i'm not sure it's big
enough i know
you know what i feel like every hour i'm
spending with samuel
i find more and more reasons to make me
want to get into real estate like
just when i thought i couldn't feel any
more motivated he says to me
come to my house live it's massive and
we've got a hot tub and i'm like a hot
tub okay that could be cool like a meter
by meter how we both going to fit in it
he undersold the hell out of this hot
tub this is not a hot tub this
this this is a swimming pool this is
bigger than my local leicester center's
pool look at it it's got bubbles and all
sorts
i get lost in it so we're gonna go in
now disclaimer i do get a tiny tiny
discount off the hot tub
for featuring it in a youtube video so
i'm going to leave a link in the
description that's my disclaimer okay
i'm not becoming an influencer now i'm a
property guy
but uh was that really cringing would
you not say that no you nailed it
according to liv cook that wasn't cringy
and that's okay
yeah yeah all right so let's get in
there
oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah oh yes
okay this is not even a hot tub is it
live what is this swimming pool
it's like not a hot sauce it's a cross
between a swimming pool and a hot tub
so the interesting thing is banks okay
and companies
will let you buy this you'll even see on
the adverts buy now pay later
no problem it's interesting that you can
buy a hot tub now and pay for it later
but you start saying do that with a
house buy an investment property now and
pay for it later people go oh that
sounds dodgy
oh it's risky what happens if the
investment goes down it's like well this
is crazy so
invest in nice things spoil yourself
sometimes
but only do it when first you become
financially literate you understand the
difference between good debt and bad
debt
you understand what an asset and a
liability is and you're paying for it
out of your
passive income not your active income
that'd be my advice
yeah perfect are we good yeah all right
hey what's up guys my name is samuel
leeds and welcome to this week's q and
a sunday i've been investing in property
now for 12 years
and i'm going to be answering your
property investment questions right here
right now on this video
[Music]
i'm going to be answering more questions
next week and don't forget to subscribe
turn the notification bell on and i'll
see you next time
you will i'll see you in manchester
manchester 9am
by the way she's a slacker because i
still got more filming to do then i'm
going for a run
like like you've got half a day with me
you got half a day leave him to it i'm
not good
i'm going to bed i'll see you at 9am
okay day three of the shadowing vlog
and we are in the north of england today
i feel a little bit more at home here
because i was born here
raised here and i live here so i'm
excited for today i'm heading now to
meet samuel in halifax
let's go hi guys
hey thank you for your patience hello
okay when you say see you tomorrow i
didn't know you meant literally tomorrow
all right
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
i told jael though um
you just literally go
that comes off yeah yeah definitely i
think we need to know the gdp as well
because he's very should we say generous
about the numbers he's saying like that
one sold for one point three mill that
one 600 grand
we need to get accurate numbers on that
i think right yeah
[Music]
how's it looking yeah it's good uh-huh
it's good it's two
two houses for the price of one okay but
i have a lot of work it's just
internal work but um it's selling fun
potentially asking is 90. um and if you
do
them both up you can sell them for 90
each
okay um but then it looks like there's
about 35
40k worth of work can you see you've got
a couple of missing tiles
well just at the top just a few little
gaps i mean listen
you know i'm not a roof expert but if
the roof doesn't look
neat if there's little gaps and cracks
and missing bits then i would recommend
just saying you know what let's get
let's get a roofer just to look at it
yeah it doesn't look like it needs a new
roof
it might just be a little bit of
patching yeah even the link i'm trying
to press the link that i put in there
the um spreadsheet and i couldn't even
get in so i can
load my laptop
um so yeah so it's um yeah it's been i
mean it's been a long it's been a long
road
i mean i started you know living in a
council house and in hospitals at
16 years old 16 years old 16 moved out
16
living in hostels you know living really
like hand to mouth on benefits for years
and stuff
now yeah and then you know building you
know building a commercial business
buying my council house and then
obviously now going on a
on a you bought the council house that
you were living in what the council
through how was that through property
yes all right so i had uh so i built a
commercial business
a cocktail bar called tunnel london um
which is a very successful hot tub
myself check it out yeah definitely come
on down um
and uh through that i was able to
generate a good enough salary
to be able to buy my party and um it's a
sentiment to me it's one of those houses
that you're always going to have because
it means so much to me it's a milestone
yeah exactly right
yeah yeah that's it i love that such a
nice story you've literally come from
nothing
literally nothing worked your way yeah
a lot of people might think god yeah
yeah right um but actually
seriously like samuel actually
introduced me to networking
he actually introduced me to to the
industry of property
he like like so from from that course he
taught me about financial freedom
all right viewings on viewings on
viewings
[Music]
and also yes we just dropped it in at
the end
there's two car parks there's one either
side and there's more land to stretch
the land
so she's going to view that but i know
you and you're always late to your
meetings so you're not looking
we're going straight to your meeting
yeah yeah all right
i feel like you're pa making sure you're
on time we're gonna shoot because we've
got another meeting
yes you're amazing honestly right it was
nice to meet you oh this is the
professional version
[Music]
it's nice to see someone else in the
northern market
smashing it yeah yeah there's not too
many ladies up here there in the fall
in the industry oh really absolutely
amazing
yeah well listen thank you very much for
letting me shadow you are you so welcome
i can't actually remember the last time
i've learned so much
in like a short space of time but i feel
like every hour
i'm learning something new and i'm just
being reminded how much i actually don't
know
how much more i've got to learn i've
been learning over the last two days as
well just
every day's monday so it's been amazing
well guys don't forget like
comment share and subscribe because this
guy's channel
is boss all things property he is the
go-to man the best
in the country developing investing
training
you name it he does it so share the love
thank you
very much live cult out